top congressional Democrats say the
house intelligent committee's chairman
cannot be trusted with the investigation
of Russian interference in the election
California Republican deb in newness
reveal yesterday that he met with an
unnamed source and reviewed classified
documents last week on the white house
grounds he returned the next day to tell
President Trump what he learned
Democrats want Nunez to recuse himself
the president tried to shift attention
on Twitter last night claiming that Bill
and Hillary Clinton had more damaging
ties to Russia saying quote from Russia
story is a hoax Jeff Pegues is on
Capitol Hill with the new pressure on
Nunez to step aside Jeff good morning
good morning House Speaker Paul Ryan
says that he has full confidence that
congressman Nunez can conduct a fair and
credible investigation but this morning
pressure is building on the congressman
to explain his actions and reveal his
source
there was no sneaking around I walked in
I walked onto the ground said hi to
people you know did not go to the west
wing to not talk to the president the
chairman of the House Intelligence
Committee Devin Nunez said it was not a
secret that he visited a secure location
at the White House last Tuesday to
review classified documents I needed a
place that I could actually go and find
this information and review it
the congressman wouldn't reveal his
source but says there is evidence that
agencies under the Obama administration
had intercepted communications involving
members of the Trump transition team but
he dismissed president Trump's
allegations that President Obama
wiretap Trump Tower that never happened
nearly a week after Nunez briefed the
President on the new information ranking
member Adam Schiff says the congressman
has yet to share the intelligence with
other members of the House committee he
leads it's not just
an unwillingness to share with Democrats
none of the committee members Democrats
or Republicans have seen what the
Chairman is referring to shift now
believes the Chairman should recuse
himself from the investigation certainly
this is a decision that will that I
don't reach lightly and and I'm very
unhappy frankly to have gotten to this
point Democrats are accusing Nunez of
trying to shield the president in the
midst of the investigation into whether
his campaign team coordinated with
Russian operatives chairman Nunez is
falling down on the job and seems to be
more interested in protecting the
president than in seeking the truth in
another surprise move late last week
congressman Nunez announced that he was
bringing back FBI director Comey and NSA
director Rogers to testify this time in
a closed hearing that was supposed to
happen today but that hearing has been
cancelled Gayle all right thank you Jeff